what up reject nation greg and john here today to
watch the boys season three episode two yeah had
to pack up a little bit more it's the last week
here or move to the new place but guys if you can
check us out on patreon become a super sexy reject
today full length watch alongs for the boys are
over there along with a bunch of other shows that
we cover at the same tier reaction highlights and
watch alongs included if you can't do that because
you want to be a meanie not pledge money if you
want to do that leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated and your thoughts on the episode down
below also subscribe and click that notification
bell to notify when our next reaction for the boys
is up here on the channel gotta thank them boys at
prepper for helping us edit down these highlights
and please another friendly reminder this
is the boys so anything with like graphic
nerd and saying that word youtube is like
why would you say that yeah they're gonna
have to be blurred out all right or else this
will be not just limited ad wise it could be
limited just in viewership-wise it's a certain
country why won't it play so yeah guys just a
little friendly reminder the record some people
complain about that but anywho let's get to it
we can offer you a family mr adana tell
me the truth are you having me followed
i am afraid that you have become a toxic
personality dip oh no left me no choice but to run
put a cork in it zayn brought to
you by lean lighty frozen dinners
by vaughn simulcast live across vbs vtv
vnn vaut soul and vatimundo join me for
my annual birthday spectacular oh god for
sonic the cast of riverdale and of course
the cast of river dude that's right
man they they love homelanders
you really going to shoot that
[__] in your veins you know
i think i just might oh my god well i'll get one
more for less i don't think you're gonna do it
yeah wasted no time that's a new low even for
you oh i can go lower i can go straight too well
butcher you have to stop
please for becca oh my god
his actual brother she's dead
huey the canary are you mad at me no of course
not look hear your mother's son and i'll always
watch out for you all right you don't want to piss
off that little kid man that's your last link to
humanity hey there sleepyhead rise and shine big
day anything a little extra special about today
what oh it's birthday how could you forget
what if we tell butcher we tell butcher i've
been a soup sidekick for a year oh christ he's
never going to not torture me for this is he
no no no look we can handle this ourselves all
right i wouldn't do that that song was gross
when i was 18. i sing it now they're gonna make
me keep a thousand feet from schools and don't
sing it it's easy for you to say you're already
in the seven i don't want to make waves trust me
egg waves supersonic waves your
real uh contender on american hero
keep it up we could be teammates oh wow
i hope so sir of course it doesn't hurt
that the show's judge used to get
come drunk on your chorizo picante
he knew it was coming sir we're loading the
prom troopers oh that will wink i got to admit
i was a little unsure about this
but now honestly i am just so excited about what's
coming really that's good star of a beautiful
friendship i've got this for you you and your dad
can build it together 523 pieces of family fun
french and camigo is starting
with the crimson compass
and i'm gonna hit up gunpowder his soldier point
you could close the book on him once and for all
for your dad your family [__] off with
that [__] oh i might have one thing
how's that grin
inclusive kingdom brave mape's
inclusive kitchen and veggie tacos
oh no if you want to wait three hours for a
three minute ride it is a monumental monster
since when okay first work then pleasure
well how much more friendship looks in shape yeah
he used those values to prove
america's exceptionalism to the
he helped guide america
i love that she's enjoying this so much
is that a healthier way to take your medication
you seem a little old we're youngest hearts
oh sweetie can't you talk would
you like to hear something new
oh no
okay sarah mclaughlin on
how did he died who killed him talk the
show is the truth [__] he died a hero
it's not very inclusive oh no well
this escalated quickly those poor kids
how frequently does that happen here
they can't cry
give me the v24 500
peanut butter and blood hey you
got your blood in my peanut butter
we're gonna need a little more jfk
just got rimmed out by marilyn version
it's got to fit with the routine actually
show the routine you're gonna [__] love this
that's your backup this is a juvenile
attempt to get me to look like a sex doll
instead of a co-captain why don't you lighten
the [__] up ready let's hit it if starlight
doesn't want to sing she doesn't sing oh
stan a rebranding so listen we start with
the docu-series from vots soul a train to africa
boom the arts it'll trace his family's journey
from the plains of africa all the way to yeah
like i want to get back in touch with my roots
like in roots and for the gen z's a
state-of-the-art interactive learning experience
oh wow is that a video game about
the slave trade some powerful stuff
it's really something
um i'm sorry you said you don't
get many potential parents
well you know what kind of a home we are
right yeah no of course it's a group home
oh my god bright burn academy had a home like
this in boys diabolical hey can you can you uh
can you show me the rest of the place
oh okay sorry what uh what is it teddy
oh hey wait a minute i know you yeah he's
right there on the tv starlight is is the
one that sent me here i'm completely sterile we
just want to keep it about love and not publicity
this is fantastic with a superhuman mother
there is far less chance of parental fatality
you mind if i uh just kind of flip around a bit
thank you thank you sorry sorry is there anything
in particular that you're looking for um boy girl
you know we don't really see gender that way well
samir is south asian that is very hot right now
oh golly right samir right here okay south asian
unplugging it makes you lose all
the data we're getting to eject
parental fatality nadia do
you know why you're here today
did i do something wrong not at all
you're getting what you've always wanted
you're adopting me no i can't adopt you
sport oh [__] i'm gonna take care of you
no good very bad anything
in the news still nothing
this is fascinating a cleaning crew sterilized
the site within 15 minutes of the incident no
witnesses have come forward and if they do we'll
deal with them the same way you dealt with tony
come on sport haven't i always taken care of you
this is stan edgar's season here next
there you go nice piece welcome next
gunpowder time yeah i've followed
you since your payback days
14 years old picked to be soldier boy sidekick
who's a great man you must have been chuffed eh
letting him watch you on the bog stick his finger
up your bum a bit give him a sloppy little nosh
now all i want to know is what happened to
him now you're gonna tell me maybe i put a
bullet in your head soldier boy never touched me
like that oh you just beat the crap out of you
oh damn
whoa
that's an amazing eyesight there butcher
oh no time to guess i'll be 28
oh
there's really that's yeah no music
it feels like i see that terminator
2. so there's a little blue light yeah
oh my god damn
smart
it's your lucky day but considering
you're my annual birthday save
gift to throw yours away and be a real
slap in the lord's face don't you think
you don't want to go to hell
for all eternity i'm jewish
well regardless just step back from
the ledge please oh [__] come on look
i'm here now if you jump i'm just gonna fly
down and save you anyway it's all futile and
oh wow oh no oh whoa what a
weird irony it's my birthday
oh my god damn it
don't snap man please continue
saving this poor young woman
how is it fair that you get saved while a
beautiful perfect god i think you should jump
i don't think i want to jump please i i just
want to get down anymore you are so sick
no god no god [__] did she bite off her own
tongue storm for a million dollar baby herself
wow wow damn that was pretty sick that took a
turn i'm sorry i mean you're missing work your
hand a lot going on there's something i should
know just make it about starlight i'm trying
to help i don't always need your help i mean you
don't have to treat me like i'm a kid yeah i was
thinking that i was treating you like my boyfriend
well you know this is actually none of my business
excellent cover cut her some slack you
shouldn't be afraid of a powerful woman
my god all right thanks for the save by
the way yeah that was really good role play
oh um i may have signed us up to adopt a child
season four it's like soldier boys like this
this still sliver inside of my brain after he
i don't know what to do you need to go
back to butcher wow what a different season
please don't tell janine about this i just want
to leave her out of it janine will be right here
waiting stay safe for her hmm to get
monique's support they needed to break up
last missing piece
hi buddy i'm sorry i'm running late i
thought i'd have time to sneak in a haircut
just wanted to tell you that i love you and i'll
see you soon so i love you and i'll see you soon
he's really good at those brick films canary i'll
nature things are good ryan's good i should leave
it well enough alone before i go and [__] it all
up newman's a soup she's the head popper oh [__]
if we're gonna take them down we have to do
whatever it takes we have to do it your way
this would be 24 time
oh you poor pathetic soap too doesn't
have the shape-shifter guy anymore
and oh my god he took it he took
it you got to be [__] kidding me
get your ass off of my car why
are you protecting soulja boy oh
like turbine
don't kill him butcher in [__] 84 but i didn't
see it happen you must have seen something i
didn't see [__] we're working with the
cia who's your case officer grace oh no
oh [__] damn it i told you everything i know
all right please just just but it don't change
what you are
wow wow
and now it'll look like homelander
did it happy birthday homeland
thank you i can see your girl you
disgusting fat get off the [__] stage
you're not she died we all make mistakes right
come on no give no no no this is so awkward
i don't make mistakes i'm not just like the
rest of you i'm stronger i'm smarter i'm better
i am better whole life rich people powerful
people try to muzzle me cancel me keep me impotent
and obedient like i'm a [__] puppet is todd
gravitated towards this todd's loving this
i am the only one who possibly can you're not the
real heroes i'm the real earth oh you crazy man
wow staring out to darkness
the mic dropped jesus that season something else
something else the no [__] season absolute vodka
huh did you say something i love this show it
is pretty great it is pretty great it's pretty
unsettling but great yes i mean it's
one of my favorite shows ever made it
it's definitely one of like
my all-time favorite shows i
i love everything they're doing
there's not a single complaint thus far
i really don't i think i think like i watched the
season one and two a couple months ago and then to
come back here and it's just i just love where
we've chose i think they i don't know if they
took into consideration how people were kind of
responsive to the first three episodes of season
two initially because i think that actually works
really strong um when you watch it immediately
after season one and but this feels like a sequel
season as opposed to picking up moments later and
just everything they're just flipping so much
around and they're they're getting past the
[__] of like prolonged buildup it's like just
enough build up because we've had so much buildup
with homelander already revealing himself to
the public of who and what he really is like
he does have this thwarted ideology of himself
and what he is that he he does have this own like
self-grandiose god-like image that he he
thinks he fancies himself to be you know
while also knowing that he is just
a child at heart this broken child
uh so exposing that and then going after vaude the
people that control him it's like he got pushed to
this point and you think stan edgar would get to
a point where he would realize that you know or
like yeah maybe maybe i'm pushing this a
little too harsh yeah if this is at least
evolve even if i have leverage and control
to some degree over him this is a volatile
substance and dealing with liable to snap and
do something horrible at any moment because he's
represent he's he's seen homelander many times
already go i don't want to listen everyone's name
that i'm blanking on i can't remember elizabeth's
shoes character name oh what's the one name
i can't remember golly ah it'll come to me it's
right there oh yeah what is her name i remember uh
i can almost i can almost taste
it i forget i forget what it is
here at the moment i'll look it up later
um but i remember it's elizabeth's shoe
but even with elizabeth chu the one who had
the most uh influence over him he would rebel
against her and she had to like do all
kinds of things just to keep him happy
you know and you'd think that stan edgar would
have a little bit of foresight to be like
maybe i need to not push as far because not all of
san agra small like really obviously the tipping
point is the death of stormfront a woman who he
like clearly loved i think that's such a great
starting point for this season because it's so
not just a physical thing whatsoever like even
destroyed obliterated uh he's still it's always
been this emotional comfort you know like even
though she's all messed up uh in the in in
her own little um at-home hospital bed yeah
she's he still like she gets off on her and
then he still connects to her still loves her
so to be that heartbroken and and then just
to get to this [__] point you know like ever
it doesn't matter anymore like it just doesn't
matter that does the the one last person alive
yeah who he thought accepted him yeah you know
who could maybe get through to him in some way
and so he had to be at the push of the
breaking point here just mind-blowing
he's got great scenes here because he's just been
getting slowly stripped down over the course of
the last three seasons and then to kick it off
here where you know like that that scene where
he convinces that girl that at least the
way they they edit it like he could have
done a little something he could do like like a
little whole clap thing create some type of force
generating power there's things the homelander
could have done to push her um but i could see
that he just forced her to jump and uh that is a
that was like such a great scene and it's like a
such a messed up twisted scene but so well written
and so well performed anthony starr is brilliant
and uh the way they've been carrying over mother's
milk marvin's storyline because they hinted at it
he had seen that road trip moment when they're
uncovering who stormfront is in season two where
he unveils his past about his dad and then now
bringing it to this point where he's been trying
to let it go but the thing that kept him motivated
to take down supes was always that core memory
of losing his father and i like what they're
doing with him because he he's always been so
they pointed out in season two he's he's
so ocd that's a big part of him and he and
he's always the one in the group who seems
to be the most in control of him himself
and the most level-headed yeah sure he could lose
his cool and whatever but he knows how to ground
himself back to center faster than everyone else
and then to have him here where he is he's just
lost it he's losing it he can't control himself
yeah and then i have the flip with the wife uh
now support him when in the past couple seasons
it's been never supportive of this path aids all
right i'm really i'm really digging it a lot but
john there's so much to unpack uh newman edgar
starlight take it away john sure yeah no i've been
loving the season thus far as well i think they've
got a really nice gradual pace and i think one
of the things about that i mean everything you
just said absolutely and then you know with with
huey and newman and starlight you know we saw the
ads and we're like oh damn like they're that
thing he said in this episode about you know i
thought that we could do it the legit way and we
can't we have to do it your way butcher you know
i i remember people be like it's kind of like you
know kind of a revealing scene to show even though
we know it's gonna get to that point and then to
have that be like a moment from pretty early on
is just one of those ear marks and i'm like okay
good like yeah yeah because one thing i've admired
thus far about this season is that they don't
uh you know dilly dally with you know breaking
some kind of advancement in terms of the stakes or
the tension or if there's a secret or if there is
some kind of sensitive situation or piece of
information that's going to come to a head
and we are not going to draw out that tension
we're going to walk right into that conflict
and uh and so yeah i think they they do nicely in
this show to make it not as much like yeah there
are big reveals and there are these big moments
that are really distinct and unsettling but
it's also about how to deal with those in an ever
unfolding situation where it's like you can't just
make one split decision and now we know and now
we better take out newman it's like i gotta huey
has to maintain his cover and starlight also has
this weird sort of back and forth where she thinks
she's in a position to do some actual good within
the system but is also working outside the system
against the system and so yeah i think there's a
lot that's going to become very fascinating about
that because not only are they good at yes like
subverting everything we know about soups but
they're also good at kind of surprising you with
different nuances and things and i feel like
there's certainly more of that ahead for newman
there's probably more to that than meets the eye
and they're also just really great at drawing
out those really twisted circumstances finally
getting that glimpse in of like okay she was
essentially not not exactly per his admission but
essentially adopted by stan edgar and made into
his pseudo-daughter and now you know even though
that relationship seems like there is something
legitimate in there it's also clearly like a power
structural arrangement as well it's like jack
nicholson and matt damon in the department
yeah yeah exactly and it's that stuff i think that
they do really nicely to blend the things that are
so crazy and high concept than with the
things that are all too familiar to how just
you know trouble and deceit and conniving uh you
know movers in society operate and so yeah i think
the way that they've managed to take that sort
of oh [__] moment of the end of the season of
like oh damn it's the last season of damn it's
it's newman and huey's walking right into the
lion's den i think they've done nicely to walk
around in that and to make it clear that that
situation is gonna explode but there's other
stuff in the foreground happening first and i
think that makes a nice kind of rounded thing with
everything to do with soldier boy over here that
has felt like yeah it's what butchered the boys
are doing but now it's finally converging with
huey's story and huey's uh dealings with newman
and you have to assume that there's probably
some kind of deeper connection maybe between
her and soldier boy or those situations might
overlap in some way like they're good at making
this machine or this this you know they're good
at laying out a story in a way that feels very
alive and feels like there's so many different
moving parts and it is you know this sort of
strange and unnerving just world that you're
plopped into and i think the acting has been top
notch and yeah just the way they've advanced the
story so far has felt really smooth and really
graceful from the start of the season to hear
and i hope beyond i think i mean if i were to
quickly gather a prediction of soldier boys that
i imagine they couldn't control him yeah so they
had to freeze him yeah because they can't actually
kill him yeah and i love the build-up they're
doing on that too is because we have seen images
of him in the promos and we have seen footage of
him within universe thus far but of all the things
to have building the most gradual i love that
they're taking their time with that because it
does you know it hypes you up for like when we can
really get gents and knuckles in with everybody
but also i think for the story it really nicely
balances out everything else they've chosen to do
yeah there's a lot of great things that
they're doing here and i think especially with
butcher what this see is kind of what i felt
with the trailers and i feel like this episode
just solidifies it that much more is that for many
in this season it's breaking point season this is
everyone's breaking point you know like uh early
on um huey is now like i can't do this anymore
this is i broke the jam i broke the jam this
is the point now this is the point where i have
to embrace the path that butcher always went for
because clearly there's no way to to move forward
with things butcher doing something he would never
do and now he's taking b-24s so that way he can
you know go up against the supes i also think that
scene that action scene was really tense you don't
really get action scenes like that in the boys and
i remember it in season two there's like one with
kimiko and her brother on the street that didn't
have music and they just let it really sit in the
tension but nothing quite like this or um where
you got to re you get to visually realize this
almost deadshot meets wanted like type of uh gunfu
fight scene and when i really gun foo but a good
gun fight scene uh and i thought that was just
so tension filled and didn't rely on on music or
hyper kinetic camera work throughout except for
that one really cool shot where they revealed
it where he he does the domino effect of where
the bullet will bounce to which was scary like
how do you fight this guy yeah you know and
it seemed like the you know it works off sound
so that's why i had like he had to throw him off
his senses by doing that which i thought was great
so um yeah i thought like that was awesome
and butcher being pushed to the point where
you know he's listening to that audio with ryan
and and you know hearing becca's voice and going
and i believed him when he was like this is it
and and so much it's such a great flip because
they are constantly flipping things because huey's
constantly like we can't do this i don't want to
be a part of this we got to get out of this and
then butcher is reeling him back in all the time
and then now here um butcher's like i'm ready
to put this away and huey reels him in yeah so
it's a cool switcheroo of what they're
they're messing with the dynamics a lot
yeah there's a lot of great twists on the
different motivations and the different
ways characters approach the situations
everyone's kind of on opposite terms
yeah i really love this uh i think what they're
doing this direction is solid the supersonic
stuff is fine like i'm not really imagine it's
going to amount to something more interesting
hopefully they that boys usually satisfies me
in that direction when i'm like it's whatever
um that's fine and uh the thing that was really
surprising to me is todd with the black wife
you know yes because clearly they're they're
making the play on and like i know the people
involved you can see them on social media and
their political opinions are very much out
there they're very vocal uh what they think and uh
yeah you know it's it's like the to have this the
person because the homelander still is associated
with stormfront while his speech was not
directly about you know the storm front point of
view yeah it's definitely gonna be feeding into
the crowd the potential for radicalization yeah
and it's so it's a perfectly eerie moment just
eerie enough when it's like damn that's that
guy's helping raise mm's daughter that's not
good oh well the influence is superheroes to
just anyone with like a celebrity power position
yeah i know yeah i'm out of influence it's
crazy it's crazy stuff i think this is a really
potent season so far and we've only just begun
that's the crazy part to me like it's just the
beginning absolutely and they're introducing
these payback players and of course going to
get the jensen knackles thing over time and and
they already got so much else going on you know
yeah well it's one it's one rare example i think
of a season that starts you know so every now and
again shows will do that where it's like okay
this time all of our main ensemble are kind
of scattered around some of them are together but
some of them are you know often different corners
and it's not the kind of situation where i'm like
come on just get them back together already like
everything is still interesting regardless of
who's where on which team working how right now
i don't think they needed to release this three
at a time i know it's like these are each one
of these is so funny it's so satisfying it's so
great individually and they feel so well-rounded
yeah it's because the show premiered when it
first debuted all at once so they are stuck
with a certain level of we have to we got to
do something we got to do some type of binge
here's the first three it's the first three
because that's a crisp number even though
i thought the first one was like wonderful
like it was wonderful and and it didn't feel
incomplete like i don't feel like or season two
i get the feeling of no you kind of need to watch
the first three yeah yeah then the table is set
yeah both of these ones yeah i've been sitting
here going i can't wait to come back next week
and like it's cool not to have to for these first
few but i feel like yeah they have really found
a way to make it very nicely episodic while also
very engrossingly binge-worthy yeah this is
uh this is wonderful stuff i'm really i'm
really digging it a lot and uh more thoroughly
satisfied great so far what do you guys think
leave your thoughts down below and uh we will
talk with you all soon thank you for being here